after all I'm with my good friend Chris
chance explained gang free has just
finished hi Chris yeah trifle I yeah
we're pretty you've got this game there
what hot off the press so to say it's
been finished and I don't know close to
an hour ago on something so we are
really quickly and doing a video yeah
and yeah it's a second white game or not
that he didn't get anything in Game one
so it was interesting to see how he
tackles um young girl from now with
white and also interesting to see if
girl from two sticks to the Greenfeld
and yeah he did in a way but let's put
some moves on the board I think I get
the idea Alan's been looking our
previous video because I don't think
many people mentioned the idea that you
mentioned haha f-free was played air
yeah this would be a quite quite good
advertisement for channels right hahaha
what stayed in an interview that he's
watched this video and did I doubt that
really yeah but ok it's it's an
interesting start line I was still
surprised that that he played it because
well the world championship matches is
usually a place for more for the main
lines and you don't see sort of sight
line soft but it's a it's pretty pretty
established by no it's not not a risky
or off if she move or something okay I'm
log affirmed 12 d 5 which is pretty much
in gruene trout style for the black
players and what I could recommend if
you want to play a creative kind of game
you can go and move 3 and 96 which is
quite interesting mine c6 yeah this this
has been recommended recently in various
books on the green felt mostly because
d5 it's not like like as huge problems
after d5 but 96 is a pretty recent idea
and it's it's
stinger 95 he got a pretty hyper modern
kind of opening well black has moved his
nights a lot but he will attack the
center with c6 and probably easy it's
also and yeah it's a quite interesting
I'm white usually I'm not sure I think
it plays 93-95 but I'm not an expert i
only know that this this variation what
was played quite a bit recently also I
sweedler this kind of wound felt number
one player okay but d5 certainly a move
three is the typical rule felt like move
and I think the next couple of moves are
pretty pretty standard the white
captures and go see four and now we see
the point of f3 there's no light to
capture so black needs to go right b6
yeah this looks some more fun for me as
whites that's without that capture this
night can be staying that on see free
now after 93 yeah 11 idea also a sum
that white quite often even goes for
long castle and yeah we see this later
in the game so Bishop g7 good show it's
a little bit like another kind offense
um with another little bit because black
has got rid of his D porn so he's got
frontal pressure on d4 ah yeah it's
still it's the very young greenford like
this this position but it's just
slightly different and it offers some
maybe some more possibilities to to
create new ideas then in the main lines
where we often have those 2025 move
deeper theoretical line so it's maybe a
little bit more of an approach to play
some chess instead to ya learn
variations by heart so I think it's
welcome that they play a little bit not
off feed but
not the absolute super theoretical main
lines ah ok so we should be three okay
why it needs to cover d for now castles
and at this point i think i'm white has
some choice can a greedy to ascertain
the main move now i'm not sure i'm just
thinking about this this is a different
line that i'm thinking of I'm sorry so
no Queen D to assess the main line yeah
okay sporting t4 maybe Rudy ones useful
maybe Bishop h6 is going to be useful to
get rid of the bushing at some point
yeah i was i was just a bit confused
because there's a quite similar looking
line but ok i don't want to get into
much theoretical things here now no
black cannon can play a lots of you
moves i thinkI five is not not the most
common 10 think i'm not i'm not one
hundred percent sure i think 96 might be
the main line but 35 is certainly a
logical move it's not a huge surprise or
something so this D poem yes is it going
to be controversial is going to be
blockaded is it going to be we yeah this
is this is the main the main point here
this deep one which will get a passport
quickly black place e6 to get some room
for its pieces I think it's often very
difficult decision if you should play
move like c6 and actually give if the
opponent this this passport which you
will get after seat XD 5e takes d5 but
if you don't play this you need to
consider that in the long run maybe c7
will get a target on the c4 good point
you were moving at all you'll see if I
might see something yeah yeah and and
you also gain a little bit more room for
your pieces and this kind of position
but you also need to consider if you
place he txt 565 this pawn is on d5
disappear spawn but it's also an
unprotected porn it's not protected by
some other porn it's not
unchain anymore so you actually have
some chances to maybe get some pressure
on this pawn which is not the case if
you get the safely protected t5 rich at
there so i think it's a it's very often
a good idea to to take them such an
advance on a lot to be too afraid of the
depot on if you're afraid of a pasty
pond and you cannot play the goon thread
anyway yeah ok actually white plays a
very aggressive move now h4 so this is
the sort of stuff I'll definitely plane
in war zones in blitz is it looks
logical like hell well yeah yeah just as
Ryan sort of get an attack going maybe
if blacks not careful yeah I think about
it I think it also has some some other
point yeah I think and of course why
dreams about yeah giving made on the
edge file but there's some other things
and one thing is the 90s on b6 so you
actually can easily play h5 so it's not
like the play h4m like has no problems
preventing it he certainly does not want
to go h 5 which is weird but it does
another point if you consider White's
position here with the porn on f3 this
um makes it quite difficult for you to
develop your pieces which is also the
the main the main problem with this kind
of setup how would you throw how would
you try to develop your King side here
this is difficult you cannot go 92 at
any point because of night seafoam
blimey yeah you're right you cannot move
yet I cannot move the night there you
couldn't before you play h form you
couldn't play night h3 because like
would capture now destroy your porn name
or information from various oh ok next
idea you need to develop your bishop
first guy to Bishop d3 this leaves t5
hanging on so you've got sort of a
traffic jam on the kingside at age 4
actually allows the rook to play some
role in the game yeah so you don't
necessarily need to develop your teeth
everyone bishop because usually you move
your bishop out also to get your look
into place on edge for guarantees that
your look has got something to do now we
will see this in the game that white
never moves the f1 bishop yeah only had
moved 20 something so this is also an
idea I try to get your work into play
get it some give it something to do yeah
if you consider that you you not able to
develop freely on the Kings side so okay
so black captured on d5 not okay but
recaptures of course and now Knight to
d7 yeah it wants to get the knight to f6
which seems pretty logical to cover the
king of bits considering that white will
play h5 and he does so immediately so
yeah after age 59 sf6 and attacking of
course d5 now again so there's free on
d5 now yep so white takes time those
peel open that HR a little bit and yeah
I mean takes on your electric captures
with the f porn yeah of course you don't
want to have the open H file so you need
to catch up the F point what would be
yeah after HC actually this is difficult
isn't it to the fiendish matrix then
yeah that'd be quite dangerous yeah it
looks at your firm difficult like he
needs to do some I think very weird move
like night h5 to avoid immediate made
yeah and nine th five it doesn't inspire
too much so FG ok capturing away from
the sensor but means that some that you
know maybe if needed will this can be
defended laterally if these yeah now
here it was it's just yeah those kind of
capturing towards the center of stuff is
nice but it does tab if you get mated
and this struggle is not such pain at
the moment if the Knights covering c4 so
this allows will be quite dangerous so
it's more justified in this position and
yeah it would it would of course be
quite quite horrible if white would get
a bishop to be three or something but
yeah it's yeah this Bishop is a problem
peace so why it supports the depot now
councils Queen's Island suppose the D
porn and but it of course the sea phone
now with the King there may or may be
the bishop might be thinking of issued
by fiber than is always g4 I suppose
which might be useful so visually goes
to d7 yeah Bishop f5 looks it looks like
an actor move but I think g4 would have
been problem also if you think g4 then
maybe Nyjah age 32 g five would be an
idea may put this on the board so it
should be seven and then maybe night age
three to go go to g5 yeah submit to you
six um yeah just one in one event idea
i'm not one hundred percent sure if this
is good but it doesn't look like
something you you want to see really mom
no now I think bish 57 looks looks
normal and what what what I would have
actually I would amaze me here we all
move for 14 and both players spend about
ten minutes here and from what from from
from from this point of view it it's not
such a surprise because well he prepared
f3 and this is one one of the lines
maybe and not I didn't look up if this
has been played already but it developed
pretty logical and it may be possible
that you get this in your preparation if
you go through the lines but I was
pretty surprised that girlfriend also
just blitzed out this stuff because f3
is not the first kind of line you you
would look at if you prepare the gun
fell because you've got so much other
stuff to cover so he seems really
exceptionally well prepared yeah it was
very bluffing a bit as possible but he's
not the kind of guy I think who's into
bluffing in many
you knew this stuff okay so King do you
want yeah here I guess there's no time
for trying something like Bishop takes
b6 with the idea of Bishop c4 I suppose
that's harmless isn't it um because you
won't have anything to blast through the
H file yeah well well one thing is if
you if you play a move like Bishop takes
bt6 you better be sure that you win
immediately otherwise it's terrible yeah
when you just given the bishop parent
you weakened your dark squares so
terribly but this this day six here is
not a big deal i suppose the King would
just go to a chai in and then there's
nothing it's hard to make the kingdom
with black special energies haven't been
existent and why it's not so yeah yeah
but it's it's something you need to
consider of course if it if it's winning
it's a good move but otherwise Bishop
takes me six yeah it's a Mormon risky
very very commercial for some of ya so
in SIDS King King be one yeah it seems
much more sensible just keep the
pressure on I get the King into a little
bit of safety yeah I guess he liked
lathrop CA do you need to do this anyway
because the firewood air so it's a
prophylactic move and also King a one
getting this the King into safety and
also well what kind of what are the
moves should white play it's been
difficult you you cannot develop your
pieces on the king's son in it's just
the same as I said a couple of minutes
ago you cannot move your bishop you you
could play Knight age three but yeah
this in this position I'm black I guess
but doesn't want to play this others he
played a different move here but nice
you fool I guess you do just take that
here yeah this this sort of solves
White's development issue right yeah and
now you've got I don't know um what do
you think of this position maybe just
bishop by six um yeah i'm not i'm not
sure if you should try something the
abisha page takes is some a bit
controversial also you can look the
google buzz you like to yeah
maybe it's a it's even a technical
problem yeah this is even better maybe
just not GE too yeah right and then take
your time of bashir covers the phone and
then yeah that's the whites development
is fine it's not sort of inhibited as it
is sort of there in each other's Wyatt
moment the pieces aren't they um yeah I
would try to try something like if like
allows me to get the night of g3 and
play clay night till you fall in this
position but Nancy for looks a bit them
against the spirit of the position
instead black yeah this lip sames to
liberate the bishop and there's a target
on sea fries exposed yeah this is of
course a very dynamic choice but it's
very much in the spirit of this position
I guess to to open it up and what what
should wide play here let's say let's
say white would play FDX e4 and now you
can consider you have rook takes this
interesting oh we take C 394 words i
think the immediate disaster yeah
absolutely looks absolutely terrible for
this which show going to see free that
looks an absolute disaster but Quinn
take C free um I'm not so sure but this
year hmm is there something all right so
it's tricky when I queen bee three
Bishop a force and quiet yeah sing and
now there are some tricks black is very
active but I'm not sure if it's if it's
so great when they 30 enough six hits be
too and also friends Queen takes
sometimes not not not at the moment but
but Queen f6 would be maybe an
interesting move yeah yeah you're right
this is this is very dangerous what what
is white doing now let's say Bishop
before you can you can capture on d4
because at once who diz yeah cool
mansae yeah hot one is hanging yes ouch
yeah so this is the kind of tactical
dangers lurking for why it did seem
White's back rank was was very weak
throughout this game actually yeah a
long time it was so black and I'm not
quite sure about rook's III really if
this is a maybe maybe there's this
something else just if you if everything
else fails on F takes e4 you could also
play like 9 a-4 wouldn't be bad but
rocks III is very dangerous though I am
but you can also could play this it's
not not bad at all I think yeah actually
this is one of the themes I want to
discuss with you in another video so in
a general video because you know
sometimes you've got a choice of aiming
for a minimal advantage with greater
safety or going for the absolute maximum
you know so you know this is like a more
safer move brooksy freeze more committal
but might promise more maybe no do you
to hear but I was thinking about stuff
like this like that's an idea now known
I do you for maybe oh me too yeah yeah
stuff like this it's of course pure
tactics yeah so we would need more time
to really assess this but it's looking
very dangerous you should be a five
maybe setting up a pin yeah g3 visual
not if you are very dangerous yeah
that's that's very much that's really a
multitude of good good possibilities
yeah okay um so in the game after efore
Anand was one thing just to neutralize
this bishop it's say yeah Bishop c4 if
you look at lines like this year's very
understandable that you want to control
this it's like a dragon bishi Bashi it's
like a Sicilian dragon bishop almost
well and yeah dangerous is pointing a
wise Kings across the diagonal here so
um yeah why not neutralize it so but the
pressures
increased on c3 here with night a four
and what you think of this move night I
for looks quite logical yeah wants to
get rid of one of whites few develop
pieces at well white is not very well
developed and usually it's a good idea
to exchange the few pieces that he has
developed so and b6 was wasn't such a
great position for the night and also it
allows the Queen to move out and we see
it immediately not g2 oh yes Queen I
five is facilitated now with 94 as well
so on energy to Queen if I was actually
used it sits appeared and it's used
straightaway this new option ya know
with this but this summer seems to
involve oh yeah this point sacrifice
that we get here because why just played
night xe4 yes hitting the Queen and
preparing this recent ugh check so I
don't know how to pronounce me since
I've roughly perhaps you you know how to
pronounce it how do you pronounce wishes
are sniffing soak the course of course
so yes sir so we have one of those here
of skweet XD to know what what else
black can play here as yet I think this
is pretty much only moose you cannot
retreat the Queen this wouldn't make any
sense but as we can see in them in the
game black gum retained some active
pieces so it wasn't a blunder or
something he you just thought it would
be I think the best option to keep his
pieces active some night takes f6 no
rook takes rook takes f6 yes because
that speeds up the rook being able to
either like harass the porn while the
main thing I think to put pressure on
the porn on anything there's any other
attacking possibilities um yay went to
f5 oh sorry there is also broke out the
fire broke out five as well as to attack
the pawn as root d 60 in this in this
position rook air-five
yeah this was played and now yeah what
else should white do okay exchanged on
g7 so he speeded up the pressure on d5
it if he had played Bishop takes f6 this
would be clearly a little bit better for
white one little winning for white after
rook tanks Oh thud winning but you told
off loose loose a move here yeah and
again we got the same position with the
rook on f5 yeah sure yeah sectors
immediately yes that was quite neat
little trick yeah routing such things so
now ruka fiber immediate problems for
white to solve it seems it seems a bit
scary this lack of development and the
back row witness frets hair so this
night's kind of defensive but why can at
least get rid of that horrible bishop
now or Bishop takes g7 without getting
my head immediately yeah I took them
then then play to d6 immediately
advancing yeah the the only trump card
that white has white has an extra porn
and a strong easter porn during the live
stream i was thinking someone mentioned
i thought this is a cute move rook age 4
but i'm not sure there's a back row
weakness here which can be tactically
exploited because we'll catch for
promises to be able to defend the porn
but i think the promises is smashed
because Knight b6 brooke here i think
that there might be some sort of
deflection going on um as she make me
and i'm not sure i'm not entirely sure
um hmm what you think I threw cake for
yeah rock edge for I think this this was
also mentioned by a young team on who
did the live commentary em on the
official side and they they analyze it a
bit and at the end sort of concluded
that it wouldn't be so great but I don't
remember and I don't see offhand
mm of course it looks risky because of
the back ring mmm yeah samake and maybe
many I'm not sure Bishop b5 all right
yeah Bishop b5 looks another dangerous
option just on the minus night for each
yeah this of course requires a very very
decent calculation so white cannot
really move this night but it is
threatened to take now on you two and
give Roxy one mate now so white and move
like b3 doesn't help it still made the
night is uncovering be to reappear with
social disaster will net because Bishop
Sykes and then f1 is here as well no
time for that because basically yeah
yeah it's a funny funny medium with
whoopsie wanted so and maybe this move
but white of course can play it move
like a three here it's tricky I don't
really want to turn on an engineer it
would it would kill my cpu anyway doing
everything else also but it's an
interesting thing which might be Allen
did have a brief look at who knows you
yeah it's to move it that that looks a
bit dangerous for you yeah because the
back rank is an issue and hard to tell I
would have need to to look really deep
into this because if it would be a great
movie would have played it and I'm
certainly not calculating better quicker
than B she's certainly something he
considered I guess because when the rook
is on the edge fun and it might be a
good idea to get it activated but maybe
we should be five awesome yeah what's
too shaky for four wide it's hard to
sell see after the bishop is on b5 how
you would develop here you pieces there
without getting compromised on the back
rank even if even if if white goes a
three here for instance to to give you
just give yourself some space
here for the king then you're still not
really threatening to move the light and
um ya know so I just had a quick look at
you know the deflections are possible
say rook d1 this deflection that takes
rook d5 deflect trying to flat the rock
from the back row that'd be a little
disaster scenario ya black ass and all
sorts of technical tricks here to to get
the porn back on on sort of irritated
white so much that he cannot really use
this spawn and I think it was so maybe a
very good judgment down by buy golf on
to to get into this position if it's
really the case that white um I cannot
do much I think in the press conference
they agreed that somehow it seemed that
white should have one another idea what
they really couldn't really couldn't
tell at which position or at which point
white could have played better so and it
was certainly not something completely
obvious alright so d6 um and look to see
five here ok logic again yeah first
things to back from eight whites haha
restricts in options box and even in the
World Championship makes you a lot o to
post some pretty it's super frenzy yeah
so roof d one seems to simply defend
against well it's important to the fend
against that and now I five I five
interesting yeah this was a bit bit of a
curious move right satoh tell them what
kind of idea there is but you you you'll
see in the game I think what what what
an idea could be but at first I think
the commentators also didn't really get
the get the smooth alright so I know he
went through page for anyway a nice
position yeah yeah but it's very really
hard to say how else why should get his
pieces into play
so yeah so that did turn out to be the
point of h4 is about the rook getting
rook into the game so but this
infiltration to the 7th phase is
uncomfortable now Roxy too yeah black
certainly has got some some good good
play here and now be three and they
don't think why should have so much arts
and now very very interesting light
would be too which is very very concrete
very concrete way to try to justify the
pawn deficit so what I think must go to
be one if he goes to um II one I guess
is disaster scenario um yeah it's the
problem is that I black will go on 93 to
before any way or it is right for yes
hitting I too yeah this is what idea for
a five move here covering the whole
night says better so this rooks not
hitting the night yeah exactly so there
was some really deep pointy and I'm not
quite sure what white should play in
this position besides her boobs lining
he seems lost it looks the bishop may be
willing to spring as well if they did
Steph yeah maybe you can play naughty
foster but it looks like really very
close to do to disaster here certainly
nothing you would want to have on the
board so all right I think rupee one is
just the the more circumspect move here
no 93 of course it was hanging yeah now
I've got this night before idea yes so
Knight d4 hitting the rook and the rook
should move here and it does move so
brooke d 2 yeah you need to cover your
you'll night enter okay white ass glad
to yeah finally move this bish
hey hit with a CAPTCHA here to get rid
of that pesky night yeah yeah now you've
got this kind of position where white
has got a nice-looking knight on d4
which actually doesn't do anything
besides being dominated by the bishop
and Webster's yeah constantly need some
protection because it doesn't have any
problem that naturally protected so you
need to be able to be cautiously along
that that white is worse or something
but like is nothing active enough to
learn to justify spawn deficit iam young
rookie one is straight obvious to to go
to e7 yep activating Europe here yeah I
know um I think we are pretty much it's
not really friendly it needs the
safeguards well after this next move it
shows it's not a fret now this rook d2
means that rook see one is going to be
there if the rook leaves yep that first
rank so and interestingly now the King
comes to its own defense now with King
be one I don't know what if there's any
other better move than King be one that
seems a logical move yeah it's pretty
difficult yeah yeah but what you want to
want to play here sort of constructive
move for white it's it's it's difficult
you need to protect this this is this
the slide on d4 and yeah it's maybe
there's not a lot much else that we're
could do now here oh um is it possible
um we haven't got the back row issue now
so black can't do this because he just
lose the bishop here wouldn't he there's
no gay growth enough in there so so now
the bishops actually froze in the check
allowing the night to just take it and
it does yeah yeah there's so sort of um
yeah it's just a matter of concrete
calculation here
the true this rook endgame what needs to
take I guess to make any sort of
progress it would be a stupid to King a
one so yeah this position this is so the
open question if there's some some sort
of idea here that white could try but it
looks very difficult because Luke c2 c2
is just a very menacing prove it's going
to hand for petrol yeah and so I think
I'm white doesn't doesn't really have
much here but here I was kind of looking
at this on my iPhone earlier i had to go
away and I thought hang on while people
mentioning rook c7 I was thinking I'm
like my getting mad here I thought rook
see seconds really good I didn't really
see it what black would do and no one
was mentioning and and then mold and I'm
plays it and apparently there were
better moves there's this really
tactical move I think I was running on
chess games come on mobile and dumb of
course route c 7 has a weakness of the
last move doesn't it that the rook can
now use that he ate square to go back to
e8 yeah but I thought it was a strong
move when I saw this position but but
not but maybe there is something
tactical like d7 possible um I think
this might be that there's there's an
idea of Roxy for coming up so many just
wroxeter so yeah you know you want to
play Roxy fire how I see him now is
there a perpetual check here I haven't
checked this with with lounge and
actually I think someone posted some
engine announces anything or but rook
this might be a winning trying um I do
not turn on engine here as I say my CDs
limiters with his skype nerve thing um
but this is interesting isn't it our
rook c4 hair yeah it's really a cement
calculation here it's also not
immediately clear to me from black
cannot take on c4 on suicide line thanks
maybe it's ridiculous but and then move
like h5 with the idea King f6 getting
sort of winning the d7 porn all right
all right son like a song and I sort of
yeah just have the sort of perpetual
stuff King f60 ph7 King g6 anthem if
white wants to keep for yeah but what da
jia maybe d8 alright win big 70 the
first known as then then take b7 yeah
this is certainly something white could
could try to play for win mind you rook
d2 looks quite powerful to try and knock
out this and this pawn yeah it's not not
something easily one loss with a white
you see ya yeah I guess it's decently
active here and of course them like has
an active King and white has King would
be one so okay but this is certainly not
not the best line so like the exchange
on c4 yeah maybe there are some tries
but I think there wasn't something on
the super grade so that white could have
done they mentioned nothing like this in
the in the press conference so um
someone mentioned just repeating rook e8
to gain a bit of time in the block to
this position and think about again and
then played d7 but that was the other
one just to repeat if that if the rook
was going to go back ever but he he
played instead here rook h1 just
inviting both rooks through the seventh
and even though why it's gonna queen is
going to be perpetual check because is
actually going to be fretting mate it's
not just a simple case perpetual check
there's this fret of mate isn't there
what if the rooks here it's frightening
okay one mating that's the big y album
yeah two rocks under seventh and so so
so here there's actually a mate fret
Roque one
and actually this is the last game move
I've got I'm not sure if this is
actually the last move so i think i
might have was this actually the last
move rooked oh yeah I think it I think
it was it was I think I saw the video
and so um girlfriend took on a two and
then it was announced movement in Sodom
instead of moving he just offered to
draw which is not exactly correct but ok
they're sort of looked at each other and
and ended the game if he tries this I
think black just sorry if he tries king
d 1 then black I don't think plays check
here because then Brooks c1 also a king
takes ito no black just plays check i
think and and driving back there and
just check in and then Brooke back to
threaten again mate that's that's good
enough is that straw just to check their
yeah yeah this is the draw I think I
just thought of something would be funny
to to solve a statistic on games where
were one once I'd got to works on the
seventh-ranked I think this must be a
tremendous score have you ever seen
someone losing who gets to works on the
seventh rank and he sits at all right
yeah haha or win even with even the
opponent Queens we check as we were
checking out a game earlier I'm which we
might need to do in the future this
nakamura exactly yeah so what what kind
of game have we witnessed it sir looks
like a pretty young correct game and I
don't think that there's some some huge
swings or something why it seemed did
get better maybe with the porn but he
had this kind of yeah sluggish
development and yeah maybe pretty pretty
decent or pretty um yeah deserved draw
yeah let's do a quick overview in
summary then so it was they've obviously
seen the previous video we did with
every mentions
and now so every might become more
fashionable on them free against the
girl field so we have here a position
which white plays h4 not not just with
attacking attentions but the main ideas
seems to be just to activate the rook
and and maybe to facilitate moves like
night h3 because this night c4 is a
little painting in white side on the
queenside and so the rooks activated
kind of like this capturing FG is the
most logical here that diagonals not
such a big weakness to exploit white
protects the deep or logically and some
prophylaxis moves which we often see in
games of Coulson Kings shifting to the
far edge before an attack or something
but here it seems the King wasn't left
in peace black played quite
energetically with this e four so
there's a lot of dynamism blacks trying
to get but a queen a five even sort of
positional porn sacrifice for long-term
pressure here with Korean a five and two
if we look at this it's still a bit too
remarkable that he did this God bleck
could have also and set off giving this
point II could have also taken on f3
it's it's not a move that's looking too
terrible but yeah just it's it's
something you you you you know you
consider instead of sacrificing this
pawn it says it takes take some courage
to to go into an essentially a sort of
endgame with the pawn down instead of
playing this but he was obviously very
confident that likes activity is enough
and he never looked really worried to be
understood okay the convenience Accra
physis this before horn yeah so um yeah
his rooks rooks a good hair after work
takes f6 the rook coming aggressively to
attack that deep horn yeah so bishops
[ __ ] strange off for now this d6 and
white was
White was skinning on sorry what it was
skiing on thin ice a little bit here
with blacks pieces will a five
aggressive intentions as we saw where in
some variations it's useful to support
the beef all night when it comes to be
four so here after Roxy to be frayed the
night is making a route to come to be
four to coordinate a to attack but that
was factored in by white so Knight d4
hitting both of the rook and exposing an
attack on the night ready to get rid of
that pesky night which he does but now
again blacks rooks remain active and and
sufficient to get a draw even though why
it's got that you usually the deep owns
one of the best pass pawns you can get
right here that the activity of the
black rooks seems to secure the draw
quite comfortably yeah so yeah that was
an exciting draw though much more
exciting that you think than the other
two drawers yeah sure it was suddenly a
bit more ambitious from from website and
also to play this kind of line it's this
f3 and what followed is not exactly a
conservative line white was playing
officiously but a thing down looked like
very very good defense by my girl
frontier sacrificing this pawn and
retaining a compensation even in the end
game so yeah I thought I think for me
this is the most exciting so far this
game yeah it's um has some dynamism in
it out and a long time porn sackful
active pieces i think is quite exciting
yeah and if you look at the the match
now i think there was one pretty pretty
good and I think very very true
statement in the press conference that
was one journalist was asking if the
next forum forum for
games will decide the match and this is
actually a pretty decent point because
if you look at this now I don't head to
white snow next game will be girlfriend
white then one black game Barnard
galfond white and then we add this at
the middle of the match where the colors
are switched so game six will be a gaffe
on white and game game seven will be
girlfriend white also not sure if you
were well that they don't they don't
alternate all the way through they
switch it in the middle of the match so
ah because it is considered to be a bit
unfair if the the player playing white
first the first game would would have an
advantage so they switch it in the
middle so next four games will see three
times careful as white oh and the vm
doesn't get any plus go out of this some
it's difficult so it's hard to see him
winning with black and some reason if
you wince then it will most most likely
we be with why its own and if it's a
level school that go into a faster time
limit yeah if it's 66 so they only play
a rapid chess and I think you never know
with this kind of tie breaks are I think
a different situation also from the from
the North's kind of perspective than
some usual rapid games but well then
wish you would be the clear favorite I
guess yeah I think so because he used to
hoist them very fast intuitively used to
be the most fun fastest GM going yet
also in classical time controls I think
Ireland only is got +1 or from something
against Kelvin black lost five and 16 or
something it's pretty pretty close but
in rapid it's a disaster for foot Boris
it's like nothing score so he certainly
doesn't want to ok if it's unavoidable
they named a rapid of course but it
certainly would prefer to score and eat
somewhere
to sort of keep it till the end yeah all
right okay thanks Chris hope everyone on
YouTube enjoyed that will upload to both
our respective channels and okay thanks
very much for watching and okay okay
thanks thanks Ron